hello everyone and welcome to rec league
the esports show that makes
professional gamers compete against each
other in very
stupid games i'm your well-dressed host
flora shaw
here with uh orlando who's dressed as
well
that's right i'm so excited tonight we
got two professional
e-game players about to play goat
simulator
fanglory and the coveted reckley trophy
await tonight's winner
let's meet our players i'm stone
mountain been creating content for the
last
nine years on the internet and uh slowly
been getting better and exploring gaming
especially from multiplayers shooters
while i may not be
the absolute tip top best i can
definitely deliver on some content
and the stream every damn day
stone mountain 64. how you doing there
doing good doing good i'm ready to
compete today
i've been training to uh get out of my
basement and
get into these competitions although i'm
still technically here
uh still ready to compete today
hey everyone my name is jonah i go by
mrs may on the internet
and that's because i miss a lot of the
shots that i take when i play shooter
games
uh so i've been doing this for quite
some time but i was actually a nurse
before i got into gaming as a career
been a lot of fun and i've met a lot of
great friends like stone mountain 64
along the way
welcome to the show mrs may how would
winning the rec league trophy change
your life
oh it would probably give my mom
something to be proud of and can you
imagine an asian woman
leaving nursing to play video games for
a living i gotta take home
something right if i were to able to
take home
this this big trophy and
show it to her maybe she'd be proud of
me we didn't say it was big
but um it is a trophy so um it's
something tangible right
yes it is it's definitely a trophy we
can we can confirm that
to really get you in the mind of a goat
the most cursive creatures
we are going to play a little game
called goat pressions
we're gonna give you a celebrity you do
oppression of them as if they were
a goat and feel free to use facial
expressions
hand gestures famous moving lines goat
sounds whatever you need to do to give
us your perfect celebrity
go pressure mrs may you're up first your
impression is robert the near goat
you come into my neighborhood and you're
coming and licking my car
and you just everywhere
all right all right
like he was in the room he was in the
room stone mountain 64. you're up next
your impression is arm goat
schwarzenegger
[Music]
i'll be back bam
one thousand points are we giving enough
points next time no no
mrs may your impression is just go
through yeah okay no no he goes
it is that guy i know see
that guy i know on a movie i've never
seen sadly enough but i know that guy
stone mountain 64. your next impression
is
herderson ford i can fly the castle run
in
12 parsecs
it's like we were there it's like we
were there mrs may
your impression is lady baba
okay all right here we go
can't read my can't read mike you can't
read my
bob
[Music]
okay a star is born a star
stone mountain 64 your impression is go
fiery
no i don't know if i can top that but
flavor town
[Music]
you know i don't know man you're doing
great
this is this isn't the competition don't
worry say thank
god it's not
now it's time for the competition
tonight's competition will feature a
head-to-head goat
deathmatch it's simple players will be
given objective to complete and the
first person to complete that objective
as judged by orlando and myself
will win the round for the first person
to win three rounds will be tonight's
rec league championship
round one lick four light blue
tracksuits and
throw him into the empty pool
[Music]
let's get ready for round one three two
one go oh my god
yeah that was great i see what you did
there with the go
and the and the guck awesome stone
you're colorblind right i'm already
owning you
oh i already know where the pool is and
i got one coming into it
this is gonna be good oh i see the pool
how the heck you get out of the pool
though oh god this is going to be a
problem
oh this is an easy wall ride that is no
problem
yes brings me back to my tony hawk days
no problem let's go
that wall jump oh no i got the stone i
got this
you wish i'm flying already my goat is
flying hey there's a buddy for you
hopefully these light blue ones
they look a little different to me but i
think that's uh
i think yeah you know that's what i was
thinking exactly are we going like a
royal blue sky blue what kind of blue
are we going here
get in there there we go here we go
hello you're filling your gas up my guy
okay how many do you have now
cause i'm about are you kidding me tell
me you're not almost done i i've
got two in right now i mean no i got
like 10 in right now so
uh come on come on come on buddy come on
get up get up
i'm just rubbing my butt down the street
oh i got my last target acquired
oh no you do not moving to engage come
here
oh yeah i'm on fire okay i grabbed i
might have grabbed the barbecue by
accident and the man is on fire
it's okay though mister i'm putting you
in a pool cause he'll put you on no
problem
there you go enjoy the trampoline that's
more in i got four
and i'm celebrating on the trampoline
oh my gosh it is a tie it is a tie it's
a first is that a first it might be a
person this is the first
it's the first time we played the go to
midday each player will receive
one point mrs may what did you think of
your performance i think i did pretty
well
i'm surprised that we both got a tie i
at first i was nervous because i didn't
find the pool and i
he found it straight away um but i think
i was able to catch up and
i could have secured that when i knew it
but oh that was so close
stone mountain 64. great job um
you were flying all over the place you
knocked the guy down pumping his gas
that was a
highlight for me as well what did you
think of your performance yeah
it felt pretty good i think i lost track
of a couple of the blue guys there would
have been a little bit faster on the
time to pull ratio that i was going for
the coefficient on unfortunately
it doesn't look like i did end it in the
tie not too happy about that but
on a couple more rounds to work with
here that's right you guys are tied with
four rounds to go so anything's possible
anything is possible just like my life
okay our players are primed our goats
are ready to lick and we are ready to
roll
we'll be right back with mrs may and
stone mountain 64 for our rec league
competition
see you soon
welcome back to rec league the only
esports show that dares to make the most
ridiculous games competitive
i'm poor shaw and as always i'm here
with my co-host orlando leyva
tonight we're playing goat simulator
let's check back in with our players
mrs may how are you feeling so far i'm
feeling great
i feel like i actually cracked that
fortune cookie
uh so i'm gonna take it as a win for me
you know i'm feeling a little nervous i
thought this game would be a little more
straightforward and
uh it is
it's something else
round two find conan o'brien and
headbutt him
the first one of you to do that will win
round two
let's get ready for round two three
two one go where
would conan be
i think i within the vicinity
of sir conan here oh studios
oh okay studio he's got to be in the
studio
okay conrad um
you already found oh minion
the studio is mine you got to bring me
on the show i
i you know i won't make this big of a
mess but uh
no promises either
whoa this is unbelievable
in under a minute you managed to find
conan and smash him in the face
under um in espanol
i don't even feel like i got to play the
game and he found him right away
incredible thumb mountain how did you
find conan so quickly
what was your strategy can't miss his
hair come on
after two rounds of goat simulator stone
mountain is ahead
two to mrs mays one
round three be the first player to put
all of your characters behind the goat
wood side
remember all your characters must be
touching
[Music]
time for round three three two
one go that never gets old guys
we got a jet pack this time how does the
jet pack
work though because that will save okay
not like that go go go go go
you got this all right is this
a wheelchair dolphin are we seeing this
right
oh zoom it zoom it baby let's go double
fins double fins
now there's an invisible wall i don't do
good with heights
i'm just out here slapping wheels let's
go baby zoom it okay now i got the
wheelchair
uh did you say this wasn't what'd you
say this was
baby can fly let's we're go
oh we're flying
yes oh we're flying
oh jeez we're not flying anywhere fast
that was the bigger problem
i've never pressed the button as fast as
this
looks cool i'm not sure if this is
something
maybe maybe if we got elon musk on this
maybe it would be
maybe it'd make a bit more sense but in
its current state this needs more work
tonight guess we're going as is
easy there you go okay we got a flamingo
next
wow what a day i woke up this morning i
didn't think i would be
stuck in a cage as a flamingo with a jet
pack strapped to my ass
can flamingos fly no flamingo come on
just get on top of that pile yes
okay that's it for round three mrs may
you
are the winner of challenge three what
do you think got you to win that round
it was super easy i didn't actually
learn how to use the jetpack until after
i won
i figured out how to use it and it turns
out it was complete garbage it wasn't
it was all scammed the whole time you
guys never told me and i was an
absolute mistake let's not be distracted
by the fact that there was a dolphin a
wheelchair
both of our competitors have two points
a piece going into our last round this
is it
[Applause]
final round ultimate destruction
you must score as many points as
possible in five minutes whoever does
wins this round will take home the
coveted rec league trophy
before the final match as is wreckly
tradition each player will have a chance
to give their goat
an inspiring speech
well goat this is it the final hurdle
you've been practicing for this little
baby licks you know your tongue
strength training in the gym but this is
it this is this is the big leagues
you have to climb the very top
and conquer stone mountain 64. i think
we need some epic music for this
go listen you've been training for this
i haven't i've spent the last five
minutes playing this game
it's time for you to step up that tongue
is the longest one i've seen in my damn
28 years of life and it's impressive the
horns
are strong they're stronger than iron
you're taking down buses still coming
back
like it's nothing you got to stand on
your game right now
for these next few rounds after that you
can go back to eating grass
but you got to tough it out for these
next few months and bring home
the dub let's get ready for the final
round
three two one go
i don't wanna do this but uh maybe i do
i don't know we'll see okay hello
everybody
looking for a good time at the fair so
many breakables
laws vases whatever place let's go
this is not a good enough multiplier
come on
line up people i found somebody's garage
and just turned it upside down oh no
headphone headphone
but it's just too easy it's it's just
too easy
i'm surprised they're not running away
honestly at this point
it sounds like they like it you may have
just found somebody's kink unfortunately
for them i
i think maybe i'm really getting the
pressure with the bench
this truck's not oh it is moving oh my
goodness
this has got to be truck on truck here
this has got to be big okay no
no points oh here we go i just really
hope this place has insurance
uh what would you file it under built
with bicycle
in hotel huge okay if you've been doing
this the whole time may i'm gonna be in
trouble
five four three
two come on pillow one all right that's
it
please put down your goats
[Applause]
fantastic great job guys both of you
really
messed a lot of stuff up and looking at
the scores here uh stone mountain he
finished with a score of
23 272 mrs may
39 518. oh my gosh let's
go
with a final score of three to two mrs
may
is our rec league champion for goat
simulator
and we present you with our rec lead
champion
trophy congratulations
thank you thank you so much my mom's
gonna be so proud of me
i appreciate it do i just get it from
the screen do i get it from you like
this can i
we haven't worked that out yet stone
mountain 64. congratulations you have
won the trophy of shame
yeah i don't know if it's something that
i should be proud of really i guess i
could put it in the back of the shelf or
something you did get it you're gonna
send it to me already got it so
okay that's it for this installment of
rec league
thank you to our players stone mountain
64 and mrs may and thank you to my
co-host orlando leva
thank you all for watching we'll see you
next time